Hello everyone, welcome back to
Trading Capital. My name is Fredy
Sarmiento. Today we have a
super special interview, truly spectacular.
We're with one of the
founders of
Debot, I don't know if he's a founder, but perhaps... well, I do quite a bit of
math, the more quantitative stuff, let's say.
Thank you very much for accepting
the invitation. Thank you very much for
having me on the show. And yes, it's
very possible that I'll have some trouble
because, obviously, although Spanish is my
first language, I don't
study math or finance in Spanish,
so you might have to help me
a little, but I'll do what I can, don't
worry. Thank you very much.
And this is really important
because... gurus are widely used in
Europe and the United States, I know, and in
Latin America and Spain, it's actually
something new. We talked about it before,
you and I... I was an
institutional trader for 11 years in
England, and when I arrived here in
Colombia, I was very surprised that there are
many gurus and many courses that
teach technical analysis, the same old thing.
So...  This is like
the tool of the future that
really shows us where
the money is moving, especially for
us futures traders, and it's great to have you
here. How lucky we are that you speak
Spanish for
our entire Latin community.
Thank you so much, John. Yes, of
course, and sure, that's it. I
obviously come more from the
options side, as we'll talk about later, but it's
another perspective on the markets, which is
n't the analysis perspective, which
I think is very important
because it's about having orthogonal signals, but we'll get to
that. Okay, well, for
the people
who are
listening, Carlos and
I work the
futures market, but we follow the range, and
besides following the range, we follow the
money, where
the money is positioned in the market, and
this tool has really helped us
a lot. So, John, tell us a
little bit about your experience in trading and
your experience in the
financial markets, if you want to share.
Yes, well, of course, it's a kind of
funny story, or I don't know, unexpected, I would say,
because I actually studied philosophy and
German, so I spent a lot of
time in Germany.  I read
complex texts, but what always
interested me most were complex systems, that is,
systems that
are almost organic, that
behave in unexpected and
even creative ways. So when I
was still in college, I started to get a little involved
in the markets
because I had made some
investments, and like many people, they didn't go
well. So I wanted to know,
well, how could I start managing
this better, controlling this, right? Yes, of course.
And that eventually led me to
options. Actually, for the first two
years I traded, I had no idea.
But I
started doing something called what I
now know is called dispersion trading,
which is that I would sell options on
particular stocks like Microsoft or, I don't know,
Amazon, and buy
protection on indices.
I would look for when I expected
volatility to take hold in
particular products and sell and
buy protection
in other places. And by
having many different products, I would sell
volatility in many places. I
thought of it as selling
insurance, basically selling insurance
and distributing the sale of insurance.
So instead of coming
from the technical side, I started from that side.  It's
really simple. Look, I was
focused on option prices; that was what mattered most to me.
Okay,
but a couple of years ago, I came across this whole
G Exposure thing. From my
experiences trading
options, I understood that it
worked because
many times I would have an
option, and the market would move
against me, and then I would have to adjust
to that. I saw how I
adjusted, so I started reading more to
see how, let's say,
institutional traders, or
big companies that sell tons of
options, adjust to
price movements. And it started
to fascinate me. Eventually, getting into
this field through Discord, I met
many other people, also
programmers, who were doing this.
Eventually, I got a little involved with Jasper,
and we've been working together for about a
year now.
We were writing algorithms, and
more recently, we created this whole
new G Spot platform. So, I don't know
if this is a good summary, but it's more or
less what comes to
mind right now. Not excellent, though.  Okay, you've already
covered the second question I was going to ask you: How was
Getbox born?
But it really is a
spectacular tool.
Sorry, Jasper, is he your partner or the
person who... but I understand
Jasper is a futures trader.
Yes, because he... he started it. And
this goes a little further to
answer the question of
how
GSpot started because I didn't start with GSpot, I
joined a little
later, but the origin had to do with the fact that we're
actually looking at the
levels of... I suppose you know them,
Spot
Gamma? Yes, of course. And it seems to me that what
Jasper is telling me is that he was
looking at those levels and was using them
and he was simply wondering, well, number
one, what would happen if I could look at having
these levels based on the volume of
options transactions instead of
just what's called Open
Interest? That's what he was wondering. And the other
thing he wondered was, what would happen if I
could see this in a dynamic way? Yes,
and that's one of the differences,
let's say, of GSpot Classic, which has
servos. There are
SIBS, anyone can more or less... and I
did it too.  Creating a chart
that gives you all the levels is
more or less public information. What's
important about GP Classic are the little
dots and also the way it
moves dynamically throughout the day, which
is updating every second. So
you can see if the levels are
growing or not, and you can adjust your
positions based on that. It's very
different from simply looking at a
static image. And that's something that,
as Jasper tells me, he didn't
expect it to make such
a huge difference. But in the
end, it's totally different. I don't know if
that's your experience too,
Fredy. Yes, it's the whole experience
because we were looking at the options chain
to see the initial volume of each
strike, and then when we found this
tool, it was incredibly good.
For example, what you're seeing here,
these little dots here, show us that
this range level at
4360, 5 minutes ago it was here at 4000, it had
this volume, which is
1249. That's millions or
billions, actually, because we're talking about
contracts.  Open
contracts, open contracts, that is, this is like
open interest, it's what... Or yes, it's a
synthetic version of open interest, that
's quite an interesting topic, but in the
end, it's what we call
classified volume. That means that
if we take all the puts during
the day that were bought and sold
at that strike and we do, how would you say,
we subtract, we net them out,
then we arrive at that number, more or
less. So we can say that at the
end of the day, in total, there are
open contracts in total, let's say aggregated.
Exactly, exactly. I don't know why it's not
loading for me today. I don't know if the
market has already closed or not. Yes, it has already
closed, it's because it takes a while
because there's a lot of data. So, okay,
I would wait a while and
eventually it goes away. Why do you use this
function every day? Not normally
every day. It's not that this... This is
one of my main tools for
trading, and one of the things
I do at night is
review my trades. So
what I do is... This is also for the
people who are watching us, this is
super important because  Here you
can load the day and
do a replay of what
happened during the day.
So it seems a little strange that
all the tabs are taking so long to
load. Ah, you know why? It's
because you're loading both
tabs at the same time, you think? So, I would
reload the page
and then click on load again.
Okay, let's see in the option profile. We'll leave
the
login, but well, for those who
are listening, this function is
super good because it allows us to see, well,
5 minutes ago, this level, and what we're going to
see now, this purple, are
the puts. These were here, that is, there were
this number of open contracts: 1216,
and
15 minutes ago it was here, and
half an hour ago it was here, and at this moment,
let's say we're live, we're here
at 772. So clearly we can see
that these puts
reached here, but they've been
selling, how would you say it? These are
long positions, and they've been getting rid of these
positions.
Yes,
exactly, John. Another question...  Your
experience, obviously, this is used a
lot by
options traders, you know, and the three of us
also use it from futures. But
obviously, to
clarify, these are zero-day options, meaning they are
options contracts that expire
on the same
day. But have you seen other types of
traders use this, more like, I don't know,
swing traders? It's basically super
focused on options and
futures traders. Ah, that's a very good question.
Well, for now, we're still very
focused
on day traders or inad
trading because, as you've seen, sometimes it's
late,
but for now, we're
only doing entries, and the reason for that is that, um,
this is very, very
effective when it comes to entries, and
we wanted to start with something very small,
simply to focus on something we
knew we could do very well.
So, I would say that most of the
traders we have do
options trading on SPX or, let's say, stocks with a
fairly high options volume,
like Amazon or Apple. I
think there are seven people who do
futures, whether they're
QQQ or NQ or ES,
and we're only starting with that
because the origin of CP was actually...
Only
SPX, but we built it to basically be
able to apply the same algorithm we
use to classify the volume
of CDT.
Actually, if you look at
the tab,
we're using the
classification results for up to 90 days. So, in the
future, the idea is that we'll be able to
expand to
include swing setups because, for
example, to return to options prof. If
you suddenly see that there are a lot of
people selling a
ton of puts below the market,
then that gives you more confidence to
take a long
trade to buy, like here in this
particular case. And that, at
least today, started quite early on SPX
because I was looking at it. I think it
started quite
early this morning, but it's also true that if you
're looking at the
monthly or quarterly expiration, there are
a lot of traders doing
that too, selling puts.
So, that could
theoretically give you confidence for a long trade.
But that's not our focus now,
but basically, yes, we're heading in that direction.
That's the goal because, for the
people who listen to us, we
do
intraday trading and...  This tool, as I'm telling
you, is perfect because it focuses on
zero-day options, on options that
expire on the same
day. Obviously, I've seen you
in the discourse where we have hundreds of
people asking you the
same thing every day. But for the
Spanish-speaking people, the people
listening to us here in Spanish,
could you explain the tool a little bit,
the colors?
Obviously, no, I'm not going to explain it,
but you, since you're the one who created it.
What is it about? Give us a
brief explanation for the people
listening here. Yes, sure.
What we did here is, first,
we started by classifying the volume. And
when I say classifying the volume, what I mean is that
when there's a
transaction, there's
always a seller and a buyer
in that transaction, let's say of
an option, obviously in this case.
But we want to know who
initiated the transaction, who
was more aggressive,
the buyer or the seller, to
know, how should I
put it? I'm
a little short on words here, but
basically we're using what's
called the volatility surface, which is the
Option volatility is the
microsecond-level change in
option prices, allowing us to classify whether the
person initiating the transaction intended to
buy or sell. Based on
this, we classify the volume.
Now, when you look at the chart,
the bars extending to the
right represent
purchases, whether calls or puts. Calls
are orange, which is the default;
the colors can be changed on the
platform. Puts are
purple. If options are being sold,
the bars extend to
the left, and the classification is the
same: calls are orange, and puts are
purple. Exactly. This is, I
think, the clearest way to
explain it. And obviously, what you
were saying this morning is very true. We saw a
lot of selling at 434, and even... Oh
well, it went up. Let's see the market, and
we started to see, for example, here we see
put sales.
One of the questions
Carlos and I were asking ourselves is, for example, all these
put sale contracts being
opened are basically
telling us, or the way I
interpret it, is the market.  He's selling
puts at these strikes basically because
the market as a whole is saying the
price isn't going to fall below these
levels. So I sell puts,
the options market sells puts and
earns the premium by betting that
the price won't fall below
these
levels. But our question that
came up these days is, is this from
the Market Maker's point of view or
from the market's point of view? That is,
this number of contracts, this
number of put sales here, is it
the Market Maker who is selling puts, or is it
the market itself that is
buying them? How do you analyze this?
We designed the tool, and this
has a bit to do with my
personal philosophy of the
markets, to show what
the customers are doing, to show what the
market is doing, not to
show what the Market Maker is doing. That is,
when you see
those put sales, it means that it's what you would
call the market buyer, more or
less, that the market is initiating
those transactions and selling.
And the reason I...  That's because
originally, when we started thinking
about G in the original
Squeeze Matrix papers, which we have on
Discord for those who are a bit more, let's
say,
studious, nerdy, it focused a lot on the
Market Maker. And the reason for that is
because the Market Maker, as we know, has a very, how would you
say,
predictable way of hedging. Of those
options, yes, of course, but the people who
really move the market are those
who are interacting with
the market, those who are getting involved
and betting directly in the
market. So, in the
end, it seemed easier or more intuitive for us, and
we tested both options, simply
showing what the customers are doing,
rather
than the Market Maker. Excellent. No, that
was an analysis we did today with
Carlos. Obviously, we
used it. I don't know, it's what I was
saying the other day in the speech: it's
screen time that one has to
spend. You can read 100 books, take
100 courses, but what an ED really gives you is
screen time. And for me, these
put sales are basically telling me the  The
market is betting that the
price won't fall below these
levels. What this does is... The
counterparty—and please correct me
if I'm wrong, John, but the way
I see it—
is a Market Maker who is
now long on puts, right? And
being long on puts, the
Market Maker's only function is to provide
liquidity. Their function is not to take
positions, and I know this because I was a
Market Maker in London at one
point. My function wasn't to take
positions for the client. Many times I was
criticized for doing so. This is one of
the ironies I find in the phenomenon that we're
talking to you, or let's
say you're interviewing
me, and I'm telling you what you used to do. It's
ridiculous, but no. I did it
in the forwards market, but
my function wasn't, for example, we've already
talked about this. Sometimes a
Central Bank would call me to give me a position, and
my boss would tell me, "Your function is not to
take the counterparty. Your function is
simply to provide liquidity. You have to
go to the market to cover those
positions."  From
my experience, I came to
futures and then to this, to the
range, but it was solely through my
experience. We've already discussed this, and I
started researching and came across
this range concept in options. But
getting back to the topic, I
know that the function of market makers is
simply to provide liquidity. So,
the market is selling them puts.
They are long on puts, and the only
way they can hedge with
these puts is by buying futures.
Exactly, buying futures to hedge.
Obviously,
they paid a premium; those who
sold received a premium. The
market maker is paying a premium. And
if the market goes up, the only way to
hedge is by buying futures.
Now, because you have experience, you
understand this and see it
clearly. The reason we created
this this way is because for
someone who doesn't necessarily have
that experience, if you're simply an
options trader, for example, the
most common question is simply, "
What are all
the other traders doing?" You want to see
where they're committed, so you can
understand a little.  Where is the risk
in the market? And for me personally,
I still, or sometimes, if I were
trading options, maybe I would think a
little more like a Market Maker. But to
simply be able to read what's
happening, it's much
easier to just think that
way and say, "Okay, where are all
the other people, where are they
positioned?" I'll give you a very, very
basic example. I have a
pretty good friend, I call him Doc
because he's a doctor, he was a doctor, now he trades
options all the time, and for him,
for example, what he wants to do is
sell. He sells options, and he
wants to sell, for example,
the
432 or something like that. He waits for the
market to
go up, and once
the market goes up a little, he sells. The
reason he can sell those...  It's because
he knows he has other traders who
also sold puts above him,
basically protecting him. If
he sells at 430 or 432, or whatever, there are
other traders
above him who sold, I don't know, at
434 or 433, and that's what will protect him.
Until those levels are broken, he
's more or less safe. And here's something
interesting for people who are into
this tool.
It's... we already did this today,
but look, it's something we've
also analyzed. What I'm telling you is...
This level, 434,
was a bit of a tricky level, as we say
in English, because it
had call sales. Basically, the
market was betting that the
price wasn't going to
go above
434. But we also had all these
put sales, which were basically
betting that the market was going to go up.
And it's something I
learned in one of the webinars.
What you did on Discord is if these
levels start to recede,
and we can see it in the points, which
I think is great, this topic of the
points to know this. What it
adds is, as we say here in
Latin America, "
fuel" for this to keep rising.
So look, look how as
time passes and the price breaks that
barrier, look, look, these calls, these
call sales, start to recede. I
mean, these people who
sold calls, I imagine they have to
liquidate their positions completely. And what this
does is that the market maker
now has to come out here, they sold
futures to cover these
call sales. Now they have to come out and
buy them back. So, if I
can give you another comment there with that
scenario, no, if they are, in that case, what
I would say is, if you can actually
go back about 5 minutes before
when it's below that
strike price. Well, what's very
interesting here is that with this
scenario, the question is very
basic: whether we're going to break this strike or
not has to do with
how much the [unclear] will help us.  Puts
below because that call we have
above is actually trying to slow us down, to slow
the price down.
Thanks, and what happens seems to me—I'm not
totally sure, but it seems to me—is that
short puts at the same strike price
actually end up growing. And that's what
helps us get past that level. And once we get past
that level, the
dynamic changes completely. Instead of
slowing us down, all those people who are now in, let's say,
underwater positions,
are losing money, exactly like that.
Instead of slowing the price down, they
accelerate it. And that's what you're
noticing once you see the
bar go down because
those things are buying back. No, of course. And
the way I analyze it
is, I'm a
futures trader. If I'm losing money on
my position, well, I close it. If
I sold and the price is
against me, what do I have to do? I
have to buy back my contract.
Although it's not much, one, two, four
contracts, they generally give it fuel so
the price can keep going up. So
I have to go out and buy, and it
's the same thing, ultimately.  Whether it's
options, futures, or forwards, the dynamic is
the same: if you sold and you're
losing, you have to buy to get out
of your position. And that's what
we saw here. It's a battle, not a
battle between short puts and
short calls, and in this case, the short
puts basically won. Exactly. Now,
something very interesting that I want us to
analyze is what you said. It's
super interesting, I
hadn't seen it from that point of view. But look,
once it breaks through the 4, we're at
434,
and this amount of call selling starts to decrease. And if we
look at
435, right here, these calls start to get scared, to get
scared. But look at the
interesting thing: they start to get scared,
they start to
decrease, and here the panorama changes completely.
Now, a total transition to selling
puts and buying and selling calls.
So,
the panorama has already turned around. So, those who
are selling puts are telling us, "Look, the
market isn't going to fall below here, and we're
going to bet on that." And we have some
new traders who tell us, "I..."  I'm going to
go with calls. I don't want the premium; I'm
simply going to buy
some calls because the market is going to keep going
up. So, it's the combination
of these put sellers here
who are telling us the market is
n't going to fall. I'm going to sell and collect a
premium. And those who are, let's say, directional—I
know it's not like that in the options market,
but they're directional—and
these call purchases
are telling me the market has a lot of room
to go up, that is, it has a
lot of potential to
keep rising. And finally, that's what
we saw today. And then look how
interesting it is that
this combination of selling puts
with buying calls works as support. It's a
spectacular support that I've seen
many times in the market. And look at the
price, because that's a
very large long position, right? So every time we go down, they
buy more.
Effectively, the other thing I wanted to say is that
when you have, now speaking
a little more about long options, not
the options that extend to the
right, if those options are in the money,
for example, if they're in the money,
then
the initiative of those traders is
basically to stay in those positions.
Because they're already making money, they want to
keep making money, they're doing well.
Uh-huh,
and with in-the-money calls, this is
also a little more, a little more nerdy,
but the theory actually favors you. So,
the longer you hold the
position, if the price stays in the
same place, then the position will
increase in value. So
you want to hold that position as long as
possible, but there's another side
to this: if you get there, for
example—no, there isn't a very good example right
now—but if we're getting to a
long call position and the price is
just approaching and touching it, it's
very possible that all those people will liquidate and
stop the price. So, if we're
below a ton of long calls,
that often acts
as a resistance level. Do you understand that?
Yes, yes, yes, yes, of course. But look, yes, you're
absolutely right. I mean, if the
example I understand is, if we had
this ton of calls but the price
was down here,
logically, these people are out
of the money, these people who bought
here. And as the price reaches, this
call increased in price.  It's more logical
that they have to sell
to take their
profits, but for example, in
this case, the interesting thing is that there were
no calls when the price
reached that point, and as soon as it passed, a
ton of calls started coming out. What they
did was act as
support so the price could
continue rising. And obviously,
for us futures traders, this
is my day, 10 points, 10, 15 points
in the futures market, this is my day. So,
this tool is truly
spectacular, and I've seen what you're
saying. I've seen it: the price is
up here, there are a lot of calls, these calls
increase in price, and then they sell
to take their profits, and then the
price comes back. Yes, the way
I sometimes think about these things is that to
read this well—and it seems to me that
this is something you have, Freddy—one
needs a little empathy. You don't need to
understand what people would do in
these situations to be able to think and
understand in a deeper way.
No, I can tell you how
all the levels work. And I suppose this
video will help, and I hope it helps.  A
lot, but with what you're saying about
Screen Time, once you start
looking at how traders behave—not what
you're saying, that they're
scared—okay, now they're scared,
now they're increasing their
positions. As you see that,
you develop a sense for the
market. And that's what I like about
this tool, that it helps you do
that. Yes, that's totally true. What this gives you
is a feeling,
a sense of the market,
of knowing what's happening in each position. And what I'm
saying is, when you told me, "I've
seen this many times, the price is
down, there are a lot of calls up," they actually get there.
I see it much better here in the
Classic. In the Classic, you can
see... would you mind telling us a little bit about the
difference between the Classic and the States
for people who might
come here and not know? They see almost the
same thing, but it's not the same. Yes, yes, of
course, it's not the same because
what Classic is doing is
simply using the volume of
options, the volume of transactions,
in the calls and the puts, and we're
multiplying that volume by the value
of the  G at that strike, uh. To give you an
idea, it's basically a bit more like, how would I
say, a volume profile?
Whereas State is more of an
active classification of what's
happening, it gives you a very
detailed idea of ​​exactly what's going on.
But obviously, what
you lose with that detail is... well, a
lot of people still like Classic
because they're used to it, because it's very
simple and intuitive. I don't know if I'd say
intuitive, but it's like you see it
and you more or less know what's
happening, you don't have to think too
much. Whereas State is
more active, more detailed. But it
takes a bit more effort, but I'd say that once you
learn it, I don't know... I like it a lot
because I've spent a lot of time
with State,
obviously. So you like State more than
Classic personally? Yes, but no, not really. I mean,
I was trading with Carlos
last week, and Carlos's words—
he's Spanish, right?—and with all due
respect to those
listening, his words were: this is... this is... what
Getbox has done is a real shitshow. I mean, it's...  I
posted on Discord the best invention
after the
wheel in Spain, this is a real bummer. And it
really is, it's because we
used the Classic a lot, and
especially the way I used it was to
see if this would load at some point, that's
when the price reached the
maximum range levels, that is, when it
reached these maximum levels and
above that I didn't have, uh, representative range levels
for me. And using
the,
uh, how do you say the methodology, no, but
the intuition that markets are
reverting, uh, that they revert to the
mean, or that they are, I mean, they tend to
sideways, no, they don't continue infinitely up
or down. This
Classic helped me a lot to
catch those reverting points.
I waited for the price to reach here, and
if it didn't, if I didn't see any more levels
here, and with another methodology that we
also have, uh, I could go
short, for example, and look for my 10 or
15 points. What I want to say with this is that
when you combine the Classic with
the State, it's, I'm
going to say it...  It's a
pain when you come
to the State and realize that, for
example, we might not see it right now. This is
my maximum range in the calls, it's
here, I don't know, here at this level, at
80, and above that I don't have much. I go to the
State and if I see that maybe all
those call ranges
are sells, that's already telling me, "Oh yeah, there's
a very large level of calls, but they're
sells." So the market is
betting that the price isn't going to go
above that. So, for those who
are listening, we
use it in combination. I
have four Getbox windows
open,
no, no, no, I swear, I mean,
my eyes have already moved
to Getbox more than the
price chart. That seems very good to me
because I don't know how you were
doing your institutional trading,
but at least for me
personally, it seems that
trading in a
vertical format, where you're thinking in
terms of levels instead of reacting
all the time to the
smallest price movements, is...  A way to
trade that's much healthier, I'd say.
Yes, yes, of course. Yes, of course. It's... It's... You
go for your points and that's it. In
these markets, the one who wants to
look for the rally, 100 points
up or 100 points down,
generally ends up burned out, as we
say here in Latin America.
And there's another part
of the tool you have that, to be
honest, we haven't been able to get the most out of,
to be honest.
But it's this part of order
flow. I don't know, I don't know if you'd like to give us
a brief description of what you
were looking for with
this tool. I
generally look at the delta, the
gets, the gam, and the
convexity, which I learned in one of
your Discord servers. When the convexity
is down, it's basically as if
the volatility is decreasing, which
makes the price go up. We already
know that it's like a correlation of
the markets, but in words, if you'd
like to explain this stage a little. Well,
order flow is a bit more
complex because it depends a bit on the
product,
as you already know.  In the case of
SPX, much of the activity is option
selling and also hedging. So,
many times what I see, for example, if
you look at the Tax Order Flow at around 3 PM, up there,
a little further to the right, there's
that very large bar, the largest one here. You
see,
we're actually marking that
as a purchase, but it's actually marking it as the
sum for
the day.
And that's because many times the
transactions in SPX are options that are being
used to
hed futures. So the
real transaction is in the
futures, not in the
options, okay? Because, well, I've been using it
intuitively. It's been
a little difficult for me to get the hang of this tool, but
intuitively, for example, I would say, look,
for example, here in this bar that I'm
showing, which is the
largest of all, for me intuitively it's that there was an
options purchase, or a purchase, and the
Market Maker has to go out and buy
futures. I don't know, it's my intuition because of this
very
large bar. That's true, that
was probably the sale of... So,
this... and
US... now in
ve  In one of
the ACs... Ah, that's perfect. So we can
see that giant bar. Let's see where it
coincides. Ah, OK. Well, that means it
was a sale, an options sale,
no, but it
was negative. That means that at that
moment they sold a lot of puts. And
how do you know they were puts and not calls?
Because for it to be a
bullish options sale, it has to be
puts. Ah, right, you're absolutely right. Of course,
because they're betting that the
market wasn't going to fall below.
So you recommend viewing this tool
in conjunction with the Convexity
Order Flow? Absolutely. Yes, because without
it you can't interpret exactly what
happened. But with the combination of the DEX
Order Flow and the Convexity Order Flow, you more
or less always know what's going on.
So in this case, it was a
put sale, and this very large level was
these numbers that tell us the
amount of Open Interest or the amount
of volume. That's what the Js tell you.
So it's the Delta Volume, exactly the
volume of options multiplied by the
Delta of that option. At that
particular moment... Okay, so here there was this
big bar. We go to the Convexity
Order Flow, which shows us...  A sale,
uh, we analyze it as a sale
of options, a sale of puts, sorry, yes.
And in this case, in convexity, everything is in
terms of keama. So it's the
volume multiplied by the keama, and it's
negative if it was a sale and positive if it
was a purchase. And in the Delta Order
Flow, it's,
uh, if it's bullish, then it's positive; if it
's bearish, then it's negative. And it's the
volume of that transaction multiplied
by the Delta. Because, for example, if
we can analyze, for example, another
moment in the market where there was a
drastic change, it could be this one here.
Look, this one at 3, at 1:30, sorry, at
1:30, we had this downward hit, which we
also see here in the
Get Order Flow, Get Order Flow, sorry, and
here we see it too. So, this is, we
can analyze this as well, it
was a sale of puts, right? Ah,
sorry, that was actually a sale of
calls, this one we're seeing here. And how do you see
that it was a sale of calls? Because
the values ​​are negative. So it was a bearish
order
flow. Okay, but the convexity is also
negative, so that...  That means it
was a sale. The delta of the
transaction was negative. But the
transaction was an options sale, and
in that case, it has to be selling calls.
Okay, at this moment we sold some calls.
The market was betting that the
price wasn't going to go up. But well, I'll
finish explaining how this tool works. It's
more complex, actually, it's very
complex. Especially with SPX. What I was going to
say is that people who use
Order Flow are usually looking at
Apple or Microsoft, other things, because
positions in SPX... Spy also works
a little better, but in SPX, in general,
positions have to do with a
very common transaction. For example, what I
see all the time in SPX is that there's a
sale of calls and puts, sometimes, and/
or a purchase. Many times there's a
purchase of a call and a put at the same time. That
means we're going to change
direction or accelerate, but we don't
know
where. And often what
very big traders do is buy calls
at the same time and then wait for a
very sharp move, and after that,
they profit from what they did with the
futures. So it's a transaction that
has several parts.  So,
to understand it, you have to
understand a little better how
options strategies in CDTs are
combined with other products, and that's why it's
a bit difficult. But what it does do
is alert you when there's a
movement or a
big event, and it tells you, "Okay, maybe you
should look at the options profile
to see what happened because something
big happened." Of course, and anyway, for
people,
we use many
quantitative tools. We're not quantitative. Well,
I have some background, but
for example, something that I think we saw in
a research shared on
Discord, which
makes a lot of sense, is that
fund managers, all these
big funds—and I know this from
experience—can't go short on
pension funds. All these giants, when
you go to JP Morgan or Goldman Sachs, if they sell you
a fund, you'll never see in your statement, "
We went short, Tesla, we went short."
I think that due to regulations, I'm
95% sure, they can't go
short. So, just imagine
where you have your
pension money and you get a statement
that...  They're short, they use the
options market, barely the market,
and what they do is sell
very out-of-the-money options.
And that's how
they generate returns against,
for example, if stocks are
falling, if the markets are falling, they
generate a lot of returns in the options.
But well, I think we
need a lot of screen time, a lot of
screen time, for sure, but I
wanted to  I recommend one thing before we
finish with that, which is to switch
to the Aggregate DAX up there, this one here, to the
Aggregate DAX, the last one.
Okay, perfect. And
then also the Net Convexity, those two
together. This is what I personally
like to use the most because, for example, there was that
hour between 10:30 and
11:30 in the morning, or let's say 11:00
AM, and the market seemed to be going
down, but the reality was
that the Aggregate DAX was actually telling us that,
using options, they were still
buying deltas and they didn't stop buying
them; it's still positive. Ah, okay, this
line, if this zero line, so I hadn't
noticed, if it's
above it, it means the market is buying
deltas, and below it means it's
selling deltas. Okay, perfect. And the more it keeps going
up, the more they're
buying using the
options market. If at the same time you're
looking at Net Convexity, you're seeing that
in general they're selling options, that is,
Net Convexity is negative. That's what it
tells you: the market is experiencing
volatility, thinking that volatility is going
to go down, and they're buying.  And that tells you it's a
risk-off day. For those
listening in Spanish, a risk-off day is a day
where the market basically buys
equities, or
buys... if I'm right, John, you
analyze it that way. Risk-off means they're
basically buying
stocks, indexes, or how do I put it? Yes, what I'm getting at
is simply that they're not
anticipating a big drop.
So on a day like today, which is a
combination of market reversal and
risk-off, meaning there isn't going to be a
very big drop, that was a
tremendous opportunity between 10:30 and 11:00
in the morning to actually be
buying and
accumulating. Excellent. So you
recommend it, especially for... well,
obviously for futures options, but
for all three futures options, I'm telling you
this is fundamental. Because look,
the market seemed to be
neither up nor down, neither up
nor down, but
actually, seeing this, they were selling
off.
Well, we already know that there's
a... well, for those who didn't
know, there's a correlation between
volatility and lower market volatility.
Volatility, the markets go up, well,
we explain that to
people who want to learn,
also with the topic of range, not this topic
of when market makers
are long range and when they are short range,
what we talked about last time, there
comes the one about markets going up
the stairs and falling out the
window. Well, that's a very
good way to interpret it,
actually. Because if volatility is negative,
that means
that traders are selling many
options, which means that
market makers are buying many
options, so the market
makers are long range, which lowers the
overall movement or the risk of the
market. Exactly, but this is really,
really, very much so. Thank you very much for
helping. It's a bit more complex, but
this example is truly
spectacular because here we see
when the convexity starts to rise a little, we
see how the markets
begin to stagnate a bit here, exactly, you
totally got it. Well,
that's what it is, and that's why this one
costs a little more than the others because it's
more of a
system, it
's not more difficult, but once you  So you understand,
suddenly you have an
objective measure, not just a visual
quantitative one, every day that tells you
more or less, okay? Today I can compare it to
yesterday, I can compare it to the day before yesterday, and I
have an idea of ​​what
the options market is doing in
general. Exactly, perfect,
John. I think that in advance, thank you very much
for your time. It's Friday
afternoon, we're all tired after
this week's rally where
nobody could
find anyone. Yes, but to finish up, I
know that you... well, we
really want to share this
tool here in Latin America and in
Spain because what I'm telling you isn't known
here. We really don't know it.
We want to make it known because it's
spectacular. And I think you have a
Getbox, you have an offer, you
can try it for so many days, you have a
discount. I don't know if you'd
like to tell us something about that to finish up. Yes, well, we just
launched the
tool. We were in
development for a long time and we just launched it, and that's why...
I think we have another
month and a half or so of the discount.
So if you go, for example, to pricing
on the
site, now it says the prices are, let's say,
50  150 250 but for the next
month and a half it's actually more like 50
100 200. Because there's a discount code,
maybe you can put it
in the video description, but it's gspot
Legacy. Because we're still relatively
new, so we
want to be as accessible as
possible to have a lot of people
start to understand and share the
tool. But basically, if
you sign up in the next month and a half,
then in the
future the medium package will cost you
100 and the one above, Order Flow,
will cost you 200 per month,
forever. So it's a discount, let's say,
a discount for early adopters,
not for the people who... how do you say early
adopters?
You know,
those things you learn in English.
And no, not the ones who are
going to... because
this is no longer a beta version, this is already
full, it's full. But we keep
changing and fixing things, so it does
n't matter. The people who
want to try it, let's say, the
people who want to try it at the beginning,
I think it's...  Early adopters, I think that's what it
means. Yes, exactly, perfect. Well,
I hope today is Friday. I hope to
release this on Monday,
put it on our website, and put it
on YouTube so people can
try it out. Because if it's going to be available
for the next month and a half, that would be
spectacular. And I also want to
mention that there's a free trial. You don't have it
here because you're already logged in, but we
also have a 7-day free trial.
So you don't have to stop, at
least start with a little bit of screen time,
start with a little experience to
know more or less what you're buying,
because obviously it's not cheap. It's worthwhile,
but it's not really worth it. And what I tell them
when people
ask me is that
with this tool, for example, with
State, let's say the person wants to
make a
$50 trade, with one trade you've already
covered the cost of the month.
So it's really not expensive. I mean, that's how I
see it. If you
do this with one trade, well, it's really
not expensive.  expensive for nothing.
But then, well, let's put
this in place. And that's it, John. Thank you so much
for your time, really. I know it's
Friday afternoon, we're all
tired, and I really appreciate your
time. And that's it. We'll stay in touch,
and thank you so much. No, thank you. I
love doing these things. I love being able to
explain, and besides, I
think that as an interlocutor, and that you
have all the
understanding that I have, you have it too.
So you
were just here
asking me questions, you know. No, no, no, no.
Before, thank you so much because you
helped me understand a lot about Order Flow,
which I hadn't had the
opportunity to really see.
Well, John, thank you so much then.
Have a good weekend.
See you next week on Discord,
chatting about trading. Okay, John, a hug.
Thank you very much. See you later, bye bye bye.